yeah let's get to the part you want to
talk about this okay let's get to the
good part the animated adaptation of
this one
i have seen i enjoy thoroughly yeah i
think it's great the animation
very good because because the boy
isn't actually a shotokan makes it in my
head i'm like free pass
i'm like it's free real estate because
he transforms temporarily so
yeah i'm willing to bend the rules
this is this is like this is like if i
close my eyes and forget it's connor's
voice coming out i'm just like
man is joey [ __ ] talking right now
what is what is going on yeah
that's like that that's like that's like
a meal are you okay with sugarcane's con
is that what you're saying
i have watched i don't know what that
other famous one is that always comes up
with like the
big big milfs and the tiny tiny kids
oh that i do not i think i wanted yeah i
can hate that one
that one is [ __ ] disgusting yeah and
i accidentally watched it and i thought
oh
god oh you know what i'm on about if
you've seen it
it's this vile it's like an eight-foot
mill for us yeah it's [ __ ] disgusting
because it's it's like [ __ ] watching
attack on titan you know what the man
it's like a pov the [ __ ] colossal
titan foxy
i don't want to watch this i don't want
this i was just like
i this this this dojin disappointed me
so [ __ ] much right and and the hentai
also disappoints me because you know why
do you know what the worst
you know the only thing worse thing than
a lolly a shodocon
i agree though i agree because because
the thing is with lollipops
right because like no they're not equal
to me because with lolly hentai i was
like i was never gonna jack up to you
anyway
it's whatever i can just skip over this
the one reason why it's so
[ __ ] hard to find milf hentai is
because 90
of them are shotokan and the thing is
most of them have like the [ __ ]
hottest milf like perfectly crafted milf
from golf crafted yeah yeah
i i don't think there's that many i
think you're over exaggerating
that's what it feels like to me right
and i'm just like all right i'm in this
i'm invested i'm ready for the center
and then the [ __ ] shoulder comes out
and i'm just like
you are this you are this close to
greatness
we had it and then you lost it they had
us in the first half
you know i i can understand the
frustration yeah
but i think this is an exception
hell yeah you know if i if i'd read the
doji and i thought
so well so what another another like b
tier
but you watch the anime version you're
like this has a place
i'm like okay now we're talking now
we're talking
this is such a one like this is such a
shyamalan twist for me because i thought
you were going to hate this one
no i i did how can i i thought you were
going to hate how when you watch the
animation of this one because it has a
lonely
shoulder in it okay the lolly one i
thought was i don't know i really like
the redhead girl yeah the red hair goes
hot yeah
i was just like redheaded girl it's
[ __ ] hot yeah showdown
why why i think it's like it's it's like
if you have the [ __ ] mona lisa and
you just decide to [ __ ] piss on it
you know do you ever do you ever see
something that happens in porn that it
like
it like hits something where you're like
oh i didn't know i was into that but
that's
very nice yeah that's like that's that's
what i like search for every day
try and try and fill that craving every
day you know the
there was a scene in it where she like
gives a hand job at the dinner table i'm
like i don't know why that was very
attractive but i was like
the red head girl i'm into that yeah i'm
like you've sold me i want to invest
how do i invest in this put my money in
this stock stocks
put my money in this stuff to the moon
that kind of [ __ ] i'm like i'm here for
it but like
i know it's terrible just like my body
my mind
but my body it's like it's like
literally that it's like i know
i know this is [ __ ] and i you know i'm
always very very hard on you guys for
this kind of [ __ ] so i feel like it's
very hypocritical
well i mean i'm just happy we found out
that you have a new favorite face which
is cheeky hand job under the table
honestly cheeky hand job at the family
table yes
what's a better genre i like danger
in in mine you like a bit of spice
i like danger not spice i don't want
ghance i don't got spices
that's me that's in danger i like the
fact that anyone could walk in i like
that kind of [ __ ] right right
that kind of stuff like having a danger
wank that's what he did
i'm not out here in the [ __ ] the taxi
wanking
i'm not saying that but a little bit of
spice a little bit of danger i didn't
expect a little bit of danger
adds a little something dangerous
but also every single you know again
like my love for
for like this thing is purely based on
the this is not even a doji thing at
this point
the dojin was mid when i was reading it
right okay so review
because because because you are talking
about the animation right the animation
is so
goddamn pineapple like finna bring my a
game
yeah yeah for some reason i completely
agree watching the
animation of this the animation for
hentai standards is [ __ ]
god what happened i knew i know what
happened this is also like
[ __ ] i i'm surprised that no one
recommended this on our hentai episode
right because it's it's just that famous
i was going to but then i thought he
would hate it no i like this
i like it because i was like i don't
know if connor's into shoulder or not
no i'm not most of it i absolutely this
is probably the only one where i'm like
that's hot
really yeah this is the only one i've
ever seen that i'm like i think this is
good that's really surprising
i'm learning a lot about you today what
can i say you know
i'm willing to bend my morals all right
so just so purely just based on the
dosion out of ten
like a six six it's it was like the
first story really ruined it
well her story was so basic so bland
so insulting none of the characters were
hot
the teacher was [ __ ] just not even
remotely attracted
i was not into the teacher character at
all and we'll get into the next teacher
character
what i'm getting out of this is like
what if like [ __ ] ufotable
i animated some lolli hentai would
connor enjoy it because their
animation's that good
i don't know i was saying i like my
hentai animation bad
because sometimes i feel like you did it
just like completely
because sometimes i feel like it serves
the story better to have like bad
animation
because sometimes the [ __ ] isn't that
great and i'm like you know it's funny
we are talking to
the one and only fan of milky right so
but for this this is one of them where
i'm like the animation is so goddamn
good
where it feels like this is better than
most anime we've been getting recently
so it's like what am i supposed to do
wrong how can i hate on this this is
just so god damn good
i'm not saying i want all hands out to
be like this because when god knows we'd
get 50 ntrs animated like this and
my mind can't take that yeah that would
be 50. fortunately the ntrs are like
some of the best
they are they always are the [ __ ]
haters
they draw this ugly bastard with the
detail of a mona lisa
and it's like why would you do this what
is wrong with you
how is the staff okay doing this like i
just don't get it but it's fine it's
like they're just they're just playing
nut chicken right
because it's it's just like it's just
like are you willing to nut to this are
you willing to not with his animation
we can't always have a masterpiece i've
accepted that not everything can be a
masterpiece you know
literally the animation watch it's great
uh but yeah this is this is good i like
the animation
the story was kind of [ __ ] but the
animation very much saved the story
you just reviewed the enzyme what they
do essentially i mean i
genuinely when i go to the second heart
i'm like seeing it skipped it yeah
i already know exactly what happens i
went okay sure it was like one for one
the same
was there a reason why you suggested
this dojin
um it's just the first one i thought of
when i thought like
you know all the girls are hot like it's
just an interesting premise like
yeah i don't know like again this is
another one where it's like as long as
you're okay with the whole show the
thing it's very inoffensive
that's a very big ass just get over the
shoulder it's fine
just pretend you're the shoulder it's
all right i don't know is it one of
those things
like is it because i'm a guy where i can
forgive it a little less
is that why is that what you mean like
with the shoulder in this case
am i making an exception because i'm a
guy and i could be like you know he's an
adult in the start of this this thing
right but if he was like a full-on kid
he was genuinely a kid i don't think i
could
i mean this is this is like a very deep
conversation
that i don't feel we have time to
explore on this podcast
maybe at least maybe maybe on a future
podcast it's definitely one of those
things where i'm like
i i hate letting the exception like i
hate letting them be like
the una reverse card kind of save it but
like for this one i'm like
ah kind of does though for me like he
acts like a
like an adult he is an adult all right
[ __ ] it all right i'll let it
like the the thing that the the thing
that turns me off originally was that
he didn't know that he wasn't a shoulder
they like you know
the girls didn't know that he wasn't
sure do you think it was weird when i
first watched it then
suddenly into him now that he's a kid
i'm like yeah because all the kills are
in the show
and i'm like there's a few things wait
wait wait so it's kind of like
when you have the siblings [ __ ] but
then they but then they'd be like
by your step siblings because
this video is under fair use i'm not
under copyright no
no because there was no moment where she
was like i'm gonna ruin your life i'm
gonna impregnate you
impregnate me ruin my marriage there was
none of that that's pretty [ __ ] hard
to deal with i don't want a marriage of
being ruined well i'm trying to have a
wank
like you know what i mean